ah ah ah eu vou comer isto
a ai ai
i
[Música]
é hora de sua autoria que falar andar
que sejam muito bem vindos
acham bb on foi só ficando atrás de mim
no novo cenário e pra quem não sabe
estava muito tempo em obras neste
divisão
[Aplausos]
agora sim parece um laboratório em série
é o que traz 24 30 e muito mato e
colchões
coisas como se fazer o flamengo pi a
bola tem um esqueleto olhem o vídeo de
hoje vai ser muito muito perigoso eo
próprio não sei o que vai acontecer
porque o leito aumente vou comer essa
aranha esta tanto aqui eu acho que ainda
tenha este dinheiro tem muito pelo ainda
que é um tema extremamente caro faz
muita comichão portanto não sei o que
vai acontecer
acho que eu vou comer porque o pronto e
não é só o cenário que não fui eu que o
estado também quer aprimorar quantas
coisas que já não passa muito tempo eu
vou falar de ignição edição vida que
merece ser feliz a 118 já entre os seus
filhos de smith copa na copa eles são
este ó weeac herói só
agora sim está um canal de um sino que
está sendo a coisa só vocês foram tim
está deixando muito aqui neste vídeo
porque eu acho que mereço acho que por
isso porque o gol eu não falo cena comer
isto é você já se enfrentaram na tarde
de hoje mas falta cópias do word doc
disse que para tudo aquilo que merecem
alguma toda toda sentimento fez um vídeo
visto aqui vocês podem ver que exigiu
exclui a troca de excluídos que me
tranco você ama esse vídeo mas tem uma
meta o número de 100.000 light silva
testamento eo trigo como é o espírito da
itaplan de vocês acham cometerei acho
que mata não sai por muita gente que
outros países sintomático mirandinha já
comer e nem violência nem chinesa que os
comem muito incertos mas esta espécie
específica de aranha
eu nunca ouvi falar coleções vitórias
dentro então a gente chegar é eu agora
fiquei impressionado porque esta espécie
de esperanto é uma das mais consumidas
em todo mundo em todo mundo atualmente
pertence mas olha eu não tenho dúvida
que tem um documentário não posso
colocar aqui no estilo porque não corta
um dinheiro que têm direitos de autor
porque o senhor falou assim eu não sei
que há crianças que correm começa
perguntando quem é e eu estamos
literalmente parada nacional fn tocar no
assunto comigo é mais uma cozinha da
escola méxico já responde a pergunta
estranha é combustível mesmo continuar a
investigar exatas ainda podem conter
algum tipo de veneno dentro e os pilotos
continuam significaria mesmo depois dela
seja de excluir que tal possa realmente
com medo
não costumo ver sim posso comer mas
tenta cozinhar da maneira correta por
isso não vou conseguir com mestrado da
forma que o imagine aí eu pensei frita
no óleo e isso não posso dizer que vou
ter que fazer com as crianças da
amazônia eu vou ter que cozinhar no fogo
porque o foco é muito importante porque
quem não os temos de ter em conta a
outra coisa pessoal muito importante e
não sei se vocês já sabem mas sempre um
meu livro eça express lucas de facto de
visão
eu não sei se você já tem um livro mas
se não tiverem pessoal o link está em
baixo não perco não vê não vai contar
muito interessante mesmo e eu estou
dizer isso sobre o grêmio está mesmo
muito interessado tem várias presenças
vocês podem fazer em casa e tem muitos
fatos que nem eu sabia antes de ler um
livro outra surpresa pessoal é que dia 8
eu gostava no continente do choque e fui
fazer uma sessão de autógrafos do livro
quando estiver em um livro a pressão lá
vão estar juntos vamos trabalhar vamos
dar autógrafo eu estou lá pra vocês que
tanto por um lapso ao ter muito menos lá
e se tiver dúvidas vai perceber que
entre uma semana mas só é esse homem
está em baixo muito obrigado e agora
vamos lá
cozinhar é nossa e te mexe com vista à
ajuda 321 o flu não falar no topo do
ferro não só temos a nossa esperança já
tem de mecanismos diretório e agora só
falta o ok fofo é aqui como é que eu vou
fazer fogo com o nosso amigo nessie como
já não existe mais perigo desde a fac lá
muito traz três do escuro que já que
estudos foi instantâneo o mundo é e
cheirar pior só falei para a cozinha
cozinhar só vou fazer aqui porque é
bastante perigoso e mexer com fogo
alguma coisa pode poluir portanto foram
fracos em maceió
e eu fui 13 - o sol já estamos aqui na
cozinha já tô aqui com minha ter ampla
funciona o mecanismo e agora vamos
cozinhar e tá esperando o irã em outubro
de 2010 vai fazer mal se ouve
eu entreguei tudo dizem que ainda espera
por mais que nem todo mundo também da
amazônia em princípio não vai fazer mal
mas sem queimar toda tranqüilidade por
queimar tudo o tempo todo 21 só para 19
mulheres livres
eu vou comer isso eu vou tentar dar uma
dica se quiser pode 321 321 com vaidade
passada ou matando em tudo pra queimar
tudo fica muito lindas parece lava ou
calma e leva tiro muito pelo neoview
abreu calma calma calma tamanha paixão a
roda a roda e isso só quero voltar um
pouco ao i que o governo só porque eu
vim pra cozinha por ter mais espaço
vamos lá então colocar a nossa tarefa no
prato olha aí muito mal
o pessoal eu não sei o que é que vai dar
ainda tem alguns pilotos mas eu acho que
já não é assim tão problemático mas
vamos lá comenta o no ju o dem tomou dez
queimada mas as cinzas é o mesmo de
assumir essa múmia estava momento é
estrada no meio eu nunca comi mas a
cozinha o mesmo estudo
- vamos chegar nem sei que eu não
conseguir meu sim alguns
agora sou um pouco vai te subir um pouco
mas ela tivesse a mesma carga tipo de
cozinha em aranha eu acho que o estado
possui o perfil de ter sido o nosso
planeta
mas para sua mãe não gostar é bom nos 2
a 1
o que só muito bom oito filha dentro dos
marcos que o corpo dela
o dem to disse que a visita a portugal
agora é e eu não consigo
ae
acho que estou sentindo a língua aplicar
portuguesas irão asp dão às crianças lá
na amazônia
o homem estava com uma criança da europa
vou continuar a comer dois irmãos quando
como estipula a saber evento daqui assim
a torcida e com um calor aqui sim mas
não dói
[Música]
agora sim generoso uma parte muito
fofinha
a melhor maneira que acho que daria o
meu boi gordo pode ser o rival ganhar
1500 e fazer o anúncio amanhã ações de
agir hospital
eu vou passar por um susto só para ver o
que se passa eu já vou estar de volta e
só vocês acham curtinho pista e fazer né
porque tudo que vivi e que vai
aproveitar mas será mesmo porque estava
com muito longe não era porque estava
sempre faltava mesmo um filme uma parte
tinha muito pelo que nem sequer me bem é
como se eu tivesse mordido um álbum
fábio pinho última maré mesmo tipo o é
de qualquer das formas que a chuva ainda
sentir se em casa precisa na minha
garganta mas já está tudo bem acho que
não preciso ir hospedar um exemplo de
boas práticas para 15 minutos de boyton
favor mas méxico uma coisa é certa nunca
mais vou cometer nunca
na sobra o brasil em breve e vou ter um
livro à venda no brasil eu vou tentar
fazer isso por isso que o brasil fique
atento e eu acho que já está na hora o
motorista máquina de fumaça muito mas só
as preocupações têm estado aqui decidir
investir em muito vai ter que meus
filhos não foi inscrito no canal
subscrevam pessoal seguindo é e se
aproxima
[Música]